[Applaudissements]
je viens bien sûr juste après des 8
juste après tes pmp regarder en direct
je suis entouré des chevaliers du fiel
je suis là dans les coulisses on a deux
pas de la seine et on est au taquet
entre nous la scène est-ce qu'on peut la
voir ils sont au pin galant à mérignac
bien sûr bien sûr alors voilà on se
prépare on met la veste eric on est
parti pour une soirée de folie une heure
cinquante aller deux heures presque deux
heures way est désert d ailleurs de zéro
donc presque presque deux heures en
direct inédit sur des beats on vous
donne rendez vous dans un instant
jusqu'à prêter pmp vous autorise à vous
regardez votre public
allez regardez regardez regardez
regardez ce qui se passe voilà voilà
ce sont les spectateurs qui sont plus
les du fiel êtes-vous dans votre salon
vous allez vivre un moment
extraordinaire sur des 8,7 en direct les
regards au taquet nous dit sa première
fois très bien avec lui
oui
[Applaudissements]
voici en tout de suite quand les
chevalières et bronze sur scène ils
seront plus applaudi tout à l'heure bien
sûr nous allons vous savez pas qui c'est
et l'effort
c'est que les pulsars bourgeois